allora bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video che dire video e una
piccolezza c'è stato il gran premio a
monza da pochissimo sono stato ospite al
gran premio sono stato di tramite live
hanno utilizzato questi occhiali rayban
per fare praticamente tutto il blog che
state per vedere quindi io indossando
questi schiacciando il tasto o
registrato perché c'è la camera negli
occhiali molto [ __ ] ho fatto vari
experience tra cui il suo su una ferrari
con
science che questo ragazzo che ha la
patente da più tempo di primi e un blog
diverso dal solito perché vedrete tutto
in prima persona varie scene tutte messo
insieme un po strano però è un
esperimento una sorta di esperimento vi
lascio al rito perché è stata una delle
esperienze più incredibili della mia
vita buona visione ragazzi
[Musica]
siamo al gran premio di formula 1
monza questa è la cosa incredibile
perché siamo ospiti di rayman e rai
barney appunto forniture
e ti permettono di fare una cosa
incredibile che registrare quindi io con
questi posso registrare in certe lo di
bloggare appunto tutto questo in modo
unico di licata aspetta vediamo se
riesce in questo momento ad attivare gli
organi con la registrazione di
sé
aspetta
la pace deve questa lista ha fatto la
lucina
e ancora no
si no in questo momento voi dovreste
vedere ermanno che non sta riprendendo
allora ragazzi questo è il patto dove si
vede un po tutto il circuito dall'altra
parte scherzavo delle luci del circuito
e di là adesso stiamo cercando di
arrivarci
facendo questo giro è una figata perché
effettivamente non mi pesa neanche
registrare parla da troppo bella
questo perché non ho passato l'esame
della patente ragazza no grazie
da stamattina alle 6 che ci danno da
mangiare a casa non ce la posso più fare
ho fatto tre colazioni mi sembra essere
da minonna è incredibile continuano a
offrire colazione perché stai vivendo
basta per sei sempre il bagno poi noi
che posso fare il duo meno geraniolo
[Applauso]
no no no no grazie
aiuto aiuto basta da mangiare basta se
neanche mia madre mi riconosceva come
sembra
bellissimo devo dirvi questa cosa
ragazzi praticamente tutto il service
parla inglese ci ha e vari
siamo tutti italiani cosa parliamo
italiani comunque anyway hanno visto
fanno sai cantare marcato dai canti a
faccia benzina così
ora casinista
sentita non è che si può fare questo
video tutto family friendly e non si può
fare
cioè mi sembra che la gente sia casata
anche alle 6 del mattino come fanno a
ricordarsi come si chiamano che io non
me lo ricordo ma che ne sapete voi le
vostre rayban moderni e iracondo
riciclone cappelli da per l'anima
peccato che sta governando tutta
smangiucchiata di arte povera di anche
il portafoglio tutto afferma lungo
l'arma dai e allora ragazzi proveremo
via
a fare un test di guida
fortunatamente abbiamo il buon ermanno
si riprende
oltre che vedere il punto di vista bene
si parte ragazzi
forza incredibile storia si alza si
muove la macchina o
mariga lavoratori
si muove la macchina
si muove c'era la pazzesca
questa patente come la butta nel cesso
in 10 secondi fantastico come sei a
pranzo visibilmente provato da questa
esperienza però gli piace non sacchi
motori questo si vede si è venuto un
appassionato di auto e ha preso la
patente subito infatti gli daresti i
miei organi
chiare
ragazzi stiamo facendo un giro sulle
due fracture che è praticamente questo
drappi che ci fa fare durano
sulla pista rubato vista popolare pochi
ragazzi allora siamo seduti a mangiare
mi hanno appena detto che tra un minuto
si siederà qua davanti a meno
alex del piero io non ho più fame mi sto
pagando addosso anche l'emozione ha
chiesto
non ho idea di non affrontare questa
gara
però la cerimona
lorenzo sarà bene vendita come stato
perché ne avevi scritto sia una volta
che ho messo una storia perché io sono
di vicino a casella no
l'avevo fatto una foto con te ero
piccolo piccolo speriamo di incontrarci
sì sì certo cavolo è successo ieri alla
fine le cose succede una cosa energetica
allora ragazzi siamo qua maranello al
box ferrari dove in questo preciso
momento sto per salire sulla ferrari con
carlo science mi porterà in pista con la
ferrari ai 300 all'ora ok
[Musica]
la donna
un po
lo dico da allora sono passati venti
minuti 15 15 20 minuti da quando abbiamo
fatto questa cosa ha iniziato a parlare
adesso non so cosa dire se non che
quando tu vai ai 300 all'ora con una
macchina sostanzialmente ogni volta che
science schiacciava il pedale è
un'esperienza pre morte perché quale il
discorso perché quando va velocissimo tu
vedi tu vedi la curva e vedi che la stai
facendo di 300 all'ora sto morendo però
poi lui farina all'ultimo ovviamente
perché i piloti sono esperti quindi poi
fai la curva è però ogni volta che
acceleri sostanzialmente il tuo cervello
ti dice stai morendo quindi ho vissuto
20 almeno una ventina tutte di
situazioni re morte che poi non non
succeda comunque veramente molto bravo
carlos è stata veramente un'esperienza
incredibile adesso aspetto due tre
giorni che mi riprende poi iniziò a
guidare di nuovo la mia volkswagen
una curva
a gomito
spalla al suo your brain sexy organ a
tale
[Musica]
il mio blog molto divertenti ste
giornate sono stati veramente
incredibili ho conosciuto del piero e no
per avere i ragazzi ma di che parliamo e
stato bellissimo è stato beh è stata una
le spese più belle della mia vita punto
ringrazio rai fanno programmi permesso
di fare tutto questo e gli occhiali
appunto per aver registrato grazie
occhiali ci vediamo prossimo video
ragazzi iscrivetevi a creare lasciato
bel commento mi piace e fatemi sapere
che ne pensate l'experience delle varie
finanza e gli ho portato e noi ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video ai
ragazzi
[Musica]